[Musique]
président de la république s'exprimait
cet après midi à la sorbonne devant les
participants d'un colloque intitulé
culture au pluriel monsieur mitterrand à
utiliser l'humour pour évoquer le besoin
d'unité nationale face à des pulsions
inconscientes concernant les
nationalités nous sommes français
vos ancêtres les gaulois
un peu romain
un peu germain
un peu juif
un peu italien
pippo espagnol de plus en plus portugais
peut-être qui sait polonais
et je me demande si déjà nous ne sommes
pas un peu arabe
je reconnais que voici une phrase
imprudent c'est celle là qui sera
épinglée
et qui c'est qui incitera à dire voyez
bien merci président habib qui l'a dit
de me répéteront peut-être 100 mètres
exactement le même sens aux propos que
je tiens
je voudrais bien que ses choix
politiques n'altère pas ce type ut pas
que puis se séduire le cas à siéger dans
des assemblées comme celle ci les femmes
et des hommes dont les conceptions de
politique intérieure sont diverses mais
qui saurait s'allier
pour refuser tous les appels
de l'inconscient je ne sais quel
subconscient mal réglés ou mal dirigé
tu serais capable de choisir
l'unité
de la france à construire
[Musique]